so so we'll just take the Ken and have
whatever your fist Gap is apart we'll
just have a a gap
apart now what I'd like you to do is i'
just like to shake it like this it won't
go dead straight because that's that
feels odd but
slightly over to the side now if you can
imagine that you've got a salt pot at
the end of your
K and you're shaking
salt out give it a little shake at the
end there so you get this you get this
little
[Music]
bounce okay keep doing
that think of it as literally shaking
salt don't put your mind don't put your
mind here think of outwards to the end
right because if you think too hard
you're not going to you're not going to
get the the point you need need to to
get
you obviously don't have
salt shake it don't have your hands too
L too tight just shake it and give it a
little
that's better yeah that's much better
that's better okay don't purposely take
it over your side like that up
and right it's a warm up exercise that I
learned anybody who's uh seen any other
names out there American called Juan
nins he used to do this for 15 minutes
before Sunday morning class when I used
to go California
and he would just do this and this would
be his warmup and he just stand in front
of the mirror
looking so what you're trying to do is
you're trying to
find how to do it and not be tense how
not to be uptight
okay so the next thing is it does now
come stra over my head touch the smaller
my back and at the end of the cut it's
like the salt again so it goes over here
comes back and then just this little
shaking of salt so
here it's it's very simple s cyto sense
used to
say the technique is strong you don't
have to be and then the next thing he'd
say
is oh senses iido is very simple it's
you that complicate it and heed the
point to us all so we think too hard you
know we're trying to perfect it rather
than just it's just an act of swinging a
wooden sword and then at the end of it
you just think about that salt so up
down
Shake Up Down
Shake
okay check each time
do you end with tension if so you
shouldn't if you're ending with tension
in your body you shouldn't you haven't
got one fist apart your hands they
should so keep checking are your hands
one fist apart or have they crept
together if they creep together just
good we always start off making it sound
so
easy and yet then we start Ping On
asking you to do things so what I'm
gonna get you to do now is I'm GNA get
you to lift it and Float the foot lift
it pulling the foot back and Float the
foot and then shaking the salt Up Lift
It float the foot shake it so the foot
arrives at the same time as it hits my
back it rides forward the same time as
the
salt comes out this is very difficult
took me at least six years to get this
one
I don't want to put you off mind you you
know but it is a long a long art that we
if we do take it on it's a it's not a
quick fix
art and just remember to shake that
little bit of salt out this was actually
designed for ladies cyto Sensi said the
ladies sort of like used to come and
just sort of stop so to help them with
their power
he said shake that salt and it's
like and so then he got the men to knock
in a peg so in in your mind a man would
knock in a peg at the end of the Ken so
right at the end of this K here you'd
think of knocking in a wooden peg into
the ground and that's what the salt does
it goes D
D D D
and and look up a little
bit and so you don't want to look
down
okay so feel that your hips are sort of
pushing that can cuz you're more
advanced this hip pushes that that sort
of sliding
foot it pushes that sliding foot